I see the Internet as the great
masterpiece of human civilization to
which we're all contributing all the
time the nearly four billion of us with
wireless access across the globe and the
reason I call it art is that the
building blocks of this enterprise the
internet seem obscure it seems like this
must be the tubes or code or a complex
surveillance state or operation of
various huge tech companies in fact what
we're looking at and interacting with
our ancient forms including texts and
short-form texts that you know first
centuries has been known as lyric poetry
and two-dimensional images that bear a
lot of resemblance to frescoes and even
cave drawings that we now see the same
tropes being resurrected on first flickr
and then instagram and snapchat we see
on on youtube we see performance and
music that might have belonged to the
ancient greeks and of course we see
music in the form of digitized music
mp3s lossless music streaming on title
so it's very difficult to me to see it
as not art these are exactly the
building blocks of of civilization the
artifacts that have determined
civilization and increasing civilization
so rather than CSS going to more
coarseness and barbarism with the
internet I see this as as increasing a
civility increasing organization and in
create and in a natural progress of
civilization the internet does have the
hallmarks of a move you know that we see
in the culture since ancient times to
increasing abstraction so so where where
online where certain interactions might
have taken place actual in an actual mob
with actual fisticuffs now you see those
things happening on Twitter in the
so-called Twitter mob with a kind of
symbolic aggression that is the you know
just it can be just as unnerving to
witness but as far as damage to physical
bodies it
much kinder and so you know there is a
great book about the arguments for
capitalism before its triumph by a
writer Albert Hirschman and he argues
that that he points out that capitalism
had a sweetening effect he cut he says
it calls it a sweetening effect do sir
it brought more it brought a level of
civilization were on a level of
civilization to what might have been a
world like interaction among peoples and
you know I see the internet as on a
continuum with that I also like of many
other writers especially early writers
about the internet see a religious and
almost theological component to to the
Internet you know I came to the Internet
by chance in 1979 ARPANET era the era of
the eve networks I was a child I lucked
into a so-called dumb terminal that I
could dial in with a modem and a coupler
to a mainframe computer in the middle of
my New Hampshire town and when I looked
at that screen that dark dark you know
screw dark dark background and then the
phosphor green letters in the front I
wanted to know what was out there I
wanted to know what was in that squeal
and crash of information I heard on my
on my modem I heard on the coupler on
the telephone and that speculation about
what that deep space behind the letters
might comprise or what the Macintosh and
iphone interface is keeping from us you
know what that what that that friendly
interface is hiding from us what that
mystery back there is that can't be
explained in simple engineering terms
it's at this point indistinguishable
from magic as our thur see Clark said I
believe that the form of the the
tradition that the internet partakes of
is realism that doesn't mean that it
accurately represents the world so you
know photography is a realist form it's
not you know deliberately artful it's
meant to it purports to represent the
world as it is then you look at
daguerreotype photo
so you look at Matthew Brady photos of
the Civil War and you see all kinds of
art all kinds of posing all kinds of
formal conventions that that hamstring
it even as it claims to represent the
world as it is now the same is true of
film you know it's the resistance to
three-dimensional film recently has said
well film already accurately represents
the world well you know the introduction
of perspective in the Renaissance you
know made painting more quote realistic
depth is an actual component of
experience so to say that to say that 3d
that adding a third dimension that
adding depth is not a way to more
accurately represent the world at least
short cells or you know represents to
like a high investment in the realism of
two-dimensional film a real real
credulity about how well we're
representing the world as it is and that
sort of that illusion the illusion that
we're getting closer and closer to more
realistically representing the world is
one that we have all the time every new
technology including science and the
compasses and and sextants of analog
culture you know claim to represent the
world as it is and the arts have
followed that too except for that
defiant push back on the realist forms
that we see with Impressionism or sake
punk music I see on the rise of vinyl
the you know the reservoir ennis anse
and vinyl sales a love of in accurately
representing musical symbols so you know
the the so-called representative form
that is the mp3 compressed musical
technology aims to be super true to you
know the idea of hot high high high
fidelity sharp realist representation of
music well the vinyl sound the muddier
sound the more mediated sound the sound
that that signals that there are dust
dust particles and air and and depth and
grooves has a certain humaneness to it
that
you know the Impressionists captured
when they left off trying to capture the
world as it is and captured a subjective
experience of the world so yes I believe
that the illusion that the internet not
only represents life accurately but is
life is an illusion and it's an illusion
we should be very aware of